students poor suckers who admit to not
knowing everything but recently that
very group has demanded stronger gun
control led by teens from parkland
Florida it's absolutely insane these
kids think they know more about school
shootings than me just because they
experienced one firsthand well I got my
facts from a meme and one of the loudest
activist voices has been Marjory
Stoneman Douglas student David hog who
recently went hog-wild
[Applause]
when over the weekend he released this
very anti gun video what if we all voted
and said this is not okay what if our
politicians weren't the bitch of the NRA
whoa where did this sharply dressed
child learn the word bitch
that's only for a wholesome sentences
like moved on her like aah
this is outrageous and FoxNews pundit
and JCPenney super shopper Laura
Ingraham agrees here's her take on hogs
video your 15 minutes is up perhaps if
one state and school one would know to
use the plural parkland student David
Hogg a new ad what if our politicians
worked the bitch of the NRA goddamn
Laura obviously the most offensive part
of what David hog said was the improper
grammar multiple politicians can't be
won bitch David that's the best way to
tear his argument down because we all
know that you don't have to deal with an
idea if you nitpick the grammar instead
after all if David doesn't understand
the basic concept of singular versus
plural then why should we trust him to
understand a complicated idea like gun
control so let me help mouth here's a
grammar lesson for the youth hey dummies
you want to call a group of people a
bitch you have to do it individually
like Marco Rubio is a bitch of the NRA
[Applause]
Mitch McConnell is a bitch of the NRA
Tim Scott is a bitch of the NRA now Jim
Inhofe and Tom Tillis are bitches of the
NRA save plural but us you have to also
be aware of tenses like Paul Ryan is a
bitch of the NRA Paul Ryan has been a
bitch of the NRA Paul Ryan will be a
bitch of the NRA until he's voted out
Republicans are bitches of the NRA see
it's very easy to say and sure some
people might say that Laura Ingraham
writing 15 minutes is up is itself
grammatically incorrect but they're
mistaken because Laura Ingraham is an
adult and adults is always right say I
just wish I could adults playing that to
these kids so guess what
I will I'd like to make an announcement
this Thursday March 22nd instead of
broadcasting from the studio bunker as
usual the opposition is going on the
road to a DC suburb where students are
planning for the March for our lives
there I will infiltrate and broadcast
from the center of the gun control
debate a high school seniors parents
living room I'll be there while students
make signs planned chants and pool their
George Soros allowances because these
kids are going to experiment with
democracy they're going to need some
adult supervision
this Thursday I will bring you the
opposition chaperones democracy kids
just want to take guns yes I'm going to
home-school them in their own home or at
the very least raid the pantry for chips
[Music]